Welcome to everyone to another Zoom call where we answer your questions or do our best job possible. Reminder to look at your member site and to look at the courses.
So if it's specifically a cancer question you have, you can open the stop by the cancer course or if it's a general health question.
You may find it on the autoimmune course of the detox course so make sure you look at your courses. Also remember to schedule yourself, self schedule can be easiest.
And if you're doing a lab review, you want to go over labs, when you get to that page, you may want to choose the zoom option so that I can share my screen and more easily point out what I'm talking about with some sort of lab group.
Alright, let's jump into questions. First of all, how do we determine what is driving our cancer glucose, glutamate, ethyl, for example, is it from certain gene variances in our genetics or for the cheek swab testing or cross tabulating both just wondering since I'm assuming that affects our diet and supplement recommendations.
So we use the cheek swab testing to find out what's driving the cancer because it changes. So it's not genetic based, there can be some genetic predispositions that you might argue with.
Let's say if you have a lot of defects in your 16 pathway, blocking the metiety and pathway, you might have access metiety, which would be available for use as a fuel source for a cancer, but even if person has access metiety doesn't necessarily need the cancer is driven by the thing.
So cancer is always just trying to find the fuel sources, always just trying to stay alive. So it's not so much a genetic factor as it is a functional factor. So that's why it can be valuable to change up your diet.
So even though initial testing with us showed that maybe it was, you know, mainly fed through glucose and we put you on a low glucose diet and low dairy diet and factors that would cause growth hormone increase in such.
It can change and then it can let's say you go on a very low glucose diet and you're keep your.
Fasting one glucose stout tone, let's say you got it into the seventies, if you were doing well for a period of time, but the cancer just took off growing again and yet your glucose is really low, then you got to go well, is it finding it on a fuel source and investigate that.
So it could change at different times. So I always want to be looking at that as if a cancer progresses.
All right, next question ever.
Red-grested grow speak at the theater. You guys have red-grested grow speak speaks where you are. Beautiful, beautiful words.
Okay, sorry, I got distracted. It's like a child with ADHD.
What are your thoughts on adding glynec, a supplement made of glycine and anacetylocystine and a glycine to give to my supplement regimen.
I was diagnosed with estrogen driven breast cancer four years ago.
No, I would not recommend that.
So, again, glycine can be a precursor for synthesis of glutathione in the mitochondria.
So there's actually genetic encoding for mitochondrial synthesis there with glycine, glycine is going to be a acid.
And that's why you would use glycine, but it can help again go back to our lectures on should you increase oxidative stress with cancer or try to decrease oxidative stress with cancer.
If a person has active cancer, it's not wise to decrease oxidative stress.
So I think the person that's asking this question is in a relative state of remission, but being in a relative state of remission, I wouldn't necessarily push glutathione type precursor supplements.
Anacetylocystine falls into that category too. So this particular brand, the glycnec is the brand is a brand that is meant to help increase the antioxidants intercellular antioxidants and help protect cells from cancer because cancer again can be caused from reactive oxygen species for oxidative stress.
From toxins in our environment, however, once you have a diagnosis cancer, like we said, those cells are already at a
dangerous high level of reactive oxygen oxygen species. And if you
technically took a bunch of glutathione or glutathione precursors, you could actually be keeping those cancer cells alive. That's why we always suggest testing.
And this particular person asked this question I've tested for these types of products, maybe not that particular product, but these types of products that are glutathione
precursors in I did not test well, so I would not do that, not use that.
And maybe this person read an article about this is a great product to prevent cancer, which you would read things about that in the supplements that are out there that are
supporting glutathione production or our glutathione supplements at our supporting antioxidation function in your cells would list
themselves and would sell they would sell the product by saying their anti cancer, their cancer protective, which there's truth to that.
But if a person already has cancer, taking those products could give you, you know, a greater chance of mortality, worse prognosis, so I'd be careful with those products.
Also, what are your thoughts of decatinamide riboside? So this is an AD plus product. Again, you are supporting the NAD pathway, which is supporting again glutathione.
So this is my own production, which is also, this can also support the, the veg asked production in an OS production, so I would not take that as a cancer patient either.
And the products that are NADH products, the products that are nitric oxide products, you don't, yes, you know, from a general perspective, you don't want to use those products if you have a diagnosis of cancer, they can, you know, they can cause worse problems for a person.
But I wouldn't, I wouldn't take those, I'm happy to diagnose a cancer. I've been on lyothyrate sodium 5 micrograms for eight years. This is a thyroid supplement. So this is a synthetic thyroid supplement. I think this is a T3T4 combination thyroid self product supplements of medication.
My skin has suddenly gone from really dry to incredibly dry and itchy. Do you recommend clear thyroid support? Well, I really would recommend getting a thyroid profile done to see what, and again, remember what a complete thyroid profile is.
So a complete thyroid profile is TSH, that's your thyroid stimulating formula, your free T3, your free T4, your total T3, your total T4, and you can, you can skip those two.
And then you definitely need reverse T3, and you definitely need TPO antibodies, and you definitely need thyroid goblin antibodies to, to be a complete, you know, these two could be left out, I guess.
This is, this is at least a, what would be defined as a complete thyroid profile.
A person can be on a thyroid medication for years, and it could be just fine, and you can be having normal thyroid levels. All these could be within normal levels.
And then something can flip, okay, so just not uncommon at all. Your, your body just isn't responding to this particular product anymore.
If you have TPO antibodies and, or thyroid goblin antibodies, how we know you have a diagnosis of Hashimoto's, so that's an autoimmune disorder, that's a total different ball of wax.
If this person who's asked this question goes, oh, I already know I have Hashimoto's, you better go on the chronic disease, and autoimmune course, and look at, I think it's module five or module six, I don't know, that's just all about Hashimoto's.
If this, if these are elevated, you have Hashimoto's, if these are elevated, and these are within normal limits, or are, or are low, this would be high, that's Hashimoto's.
If these are elevated, you have antibodies, and your T3 and T4 is super high, that you have Graves' disease, that's hyperthyroid, that would be less common.
And a person can have, and so, why would a person take this? First of all, you have two possible problems, you already know you have Hashimoto's, or you have just what is called primary hypothyroidism, which is hypolothyroid from some other reason, but you don't have an autoimmune disease.
And primary type of hypothyroid can slip to Hashimoto's, easily, especially if you're not taking proper precautions, and proper precautions with thyroid would be, you're not, you have to stay away from gluten, because gluten, gliadid is a molecular mimic to the thyroid, so if you're eating gluten, you're going to cause a immune reaction to the thyroid, and the chance you get thyroid antibodies production.
And you flip to become Hashimoto's is very high, or if you're taking iodine, so if you're taking iodine with primary hypothyroid, you're taking iodine, if you take it for years, chance if you flip it to Hashimoto's is 90%.
So, and then if you're dealing with Hashimoto's, it's totally different than you need to figure out your triggers, so I would not just say, oh, yeah, just go ahead and take this supplement without knowing some of this other data, without looking at if it is an autoimmune disease that you're figuring out your triggers and such.
And it gets some more data, so if you have had, lots of times you'll go to get, to monitor your thyroid many times, you'll be going to a primary care doctor or an endocrinologist, and they're just running this, or I've seen people go in today, I added a thyroid test, and all he did is run TSH.
It's like, it's, it's like, criminal, so you have to be tested antibodies, you have to be testing reverse T3, super important, because if you have elevated reverse T3, then you have got deliver problems, because T3 and T4 are secreted by the thyroid and are converted to add the active form.
T4s converted to T3, which is the active form in the liver, and if it's converted to
reverse T3, then that's the problem with the gut in the liver.
Okay, questions from the chat.
That was all the questions you guys submitted, so if you have any other questions, make sure
you chat them in.
My Dr. Cutters, I finally had my blood drawn yesterday from access labs.
Do my results come to you and my email, let it on a follow-up consult, call, send it
in my cheek swab tomorrow, look at everything together.
So it depends on where, do you have those done through loop-out, through our Cutters
Clinic lab store, or do you have those done, you know, did you order, okay you did order
for us?
Yes, they will come to us, and we will let you know as soon as we get those in.
Try to, if we ordered them directly, or you ordered them off the store, you'll also get
the results, I think, the same time we do, so that you can just scan them.
When you get tumors removed, and they give you all that data about them, is there any of
it important to know for a treatment movement for them?
Yes, of course there is, so they should do what's called a pathology report on that biopsy,
so if they removed the tumor, or they did a biopsy of a tumor, they're doing a pathology
report to see what that cell type of that tumor is.
If it is cancer, so you can have a tumor removed, it's benign, it's not cancerous, that
you're going to get that report, it's not cancerous, and that was the pathology report.
If you get a tumor removed, it was cancerous, then they will be testing for what type of
cancer it is, more than likely it's going to be a metastasis of the primary cancer.
We have people, maybe on this call today, that have several different primary cancers,
that's fairly rare, but it is possible, person can have liver cancer and breast cancer, so
that's why if they do a biopsy of a person who has no breast cancer, you don't just assume
that it's breast cancer, it's a metastasis to the liver, it could be liver cancer, first
of all they have to find out if it's cancer, they'll see what cell type it is, and let's
say if it's breast cancer, then it's breast cancer, but chastisides to the liver, so would
there be a change in the right program, probably not, would there be a change in maybe supplement
maybe, so it's good to get a cheek swab test done.
If it is pathology, then yes, you need to know what cell type it is.
If they do a horrible sensitivity test on it, which usually takes another week or so, you
could have a primary tumor, let's say you had a primary breast tumor, let's say it's triple
negative, it's ER negative, it's ER negative, it's PR negative, and then it metastasis to the lungs,
let's say you do a biopsy of that, and that's estrogen positive.
Why is that?
Well, because cancer can change, and that is not that uncommon actually, so it's still a
breast cancer, it's still metastasized from the original primary tumor site, but it's how it's
responding to hormones is differently, so estrogen are blocking the eight-all receptor in that scenario.
So yes, they will do a pathology, so that can just remove a tumor or not test for it, so yes,
they'll do a path report on any tumor that is removed. Any other questions?
Nobody went over that information with me from my surgery last September, so I didn't
know if I miss any important information. So I had to go back through the chronology, you'd have
to look at the chronology of your care, and see what they say about that, which should be in the
notes, the pathology report, should be in your notes somewhere, so I would look for that if I were
if you do have a mind-chart system, it would be in that, it would typically be found in that for pathology
report, post surgically report, typically the post surgically report is going to tell, is going to
explain the surgery itself, we did this and this and this procedure took this size out, and then
the pathology report would follow that, so that would be sent out of the labs. Is SCAC better to
grow in herbal form, or is the ready-made texture just as good? I think the ready-made
textures are just as good, so we can say, oh, I'm going to brew it, it's fresher, it's really
fresher at all, it's totally from the dried herb, so I think they're just as good, I think the
we don't even sell the dried herb form to brew, because I think it's just so much easier to just use it
right out of the bottle and put it in hot water and make a little tea out of it, so either way,
it's just the same point of sleep. The better the thing that is the danger of making your own
teas of dried herbs is the longer you steep it, the more you're going to get out of it, and the longer
you steep it, you can get some things out of it that you don't want to get out of that herbal
product either, so if you use something that's prepared already, then you're getting a more
even product throughout the use of the product, so I think there can be benefits left.
Can I use organic coffee from the health food store or should I use the gold roast coffee for coffee
enemies? Yeah, so let's say you run out of gold roast, what's the benefit of the gold roast over
this regular organic coffee? Well, the gold roast has higher caffeine levels, that's the whole thing,
the difference between gold roast and this organic coffee that you have, the organic coffee that you
have is roasted, and the longer you roast it, the less caffeine you have in the coffee.
The gold roast is very lightly roasted, you can't buy it, if you made a pot of coffee out of the
gold roast, coffee out of the coffee, it would be gross tasting, you would not like coffee.
It's your green coffee, so it's not, so it's about a caffeine that you're getting is the biggest thing.
So, but you can, so I tell people, people are like, oh, I don't, I try to order the gold roast,
I don't, I won't get it for a week because they might live far away or something, I just go just
go buy some organic coffee and use that, so absolutely use it, don't, don't not do a coffee
animal because you don't have the coffee animal. So, I have the report, just don't know what any of it
meant, when I get my Syrex, can we go over both? Yeah, I can, I can look at it for you and see if I can
help you interpret it. Yes, we can, you just remember, everything takes time, so I have to look
at that and then go over that with you and you're, you know, so if the more you could do try to
interpret it or more you could get the doctor who didn't try to interpret it, it may be better,
but I will gladly try to help you with that for sure. So, make sure you, if I don't have that
report, or even if, if you sent it to me at one time, if you could send it to me again, but you want
to go over that would be great. So, you did the Syrex already, I take it, so that's, I didn't see that
come through, don't think, questions. How long does it take the Syrex to come back?
You went head your blood draw last Friday, it takes a couple weeks.
So, yeah, it takes a few weeks for it to get back. It depends on how busy they are at the lab,
um, but the last one we had somebody do the all-side recess and I was surprised to play three weeks,
um, so that was kind of a pain, but which is partly depends on the ZBR at the lab.
Um, and he says yes a couple weeks. How do you feel about using flax seed oil if you have a breast
tumor? My carpractor said not to use it because it stimulates estrogen, do you agree? Well,
it can stimulate estrogen, there's argument between, you know, well-educated professionals
about the different oils. So, um, you know, some people are on the bandwagon of all seed oils can
um, increase estrogen, uh, estrogens and um, cause problems with breast cancer and cause problems with,
um, uh, you know, estrogen dominance and whether you're a cancer or not. And then there's
people on the other side that that see seed oils as parent oils and your body converts that to
better oils and flax seed oil is one of the best oils you could use, um, and they make really good
arguments too. So, um, my stance is I think the reason why there's studies and a highly educated
wonderful healthcare practitioners on both sides of that aisle is that I think people react to them
differently. So, um, I think maybe the best thing to do in that case then is to test. So, you could do a
Dutch test and um, and then start taking flax seed oil for three months and do another Dutch test
and see what it does to your estrogen levels. I honestly believe some people react negatively to
seed oil and they end up with, and even if they're all organic and not GMO or anything like that,
any cross contaminated, I think it's just the fact that they react negatively to seed oils. And some
people react very positively to seed oil. So, it's, um, that's a tough one. I just interviewed somebody
on my podcast and remember the guys they know about seed oils and he's what he falls on that side of
everybody should be taking flax seed oil. First of all, when you start saying everybody should be this
that, let's say it's wrong, you know, everybody should eat organic, but um, it is a little red flag when
you go, okay, well, I think everybody's a little different. That's what I think it is. So, you have to be
careful that um, um, you don't necessarily go down that pathway. So, I think the way to know if you
are negatively react to the seed oil, the only way to know is to test. Because you can't know if
your estrogen levels are rising just by how you feel or something like that. Now, you can't have
positive reactions. Let's say I'm taking, anyone take flax oil because my skin is dry and this
this is an issue, this is an issue and I start to take it and those things clear not.
Um, so, you could, you could use some, you know, subjective. If I need as your test, but the
objective test that you'd use is to do a Dutch test to do its test performance and see if that
negatively affects you from a estrogen number point of view, because it doesn't on everybody.
Yes. Any other questions? Um, what is your opinion on taking, uh, low dose, uh, Nell Trexel?
So, Nell Trexel is, was initially introduced into the market, it's a drug, it's a drug,
um, about 50 milligrams to help get people off of more feeding addiction.
So, I think you're talking about low dose Nell Trexel. Your test started off at 1.5 milligrams,
moved to 3 milligrams, moved to 4.5 milligrams. So, low dose Nell Trexel is an immune
modulator. That's really how it works. So, is low dose Nell Trexel good for cancer,
has an off label drug for cancer? Um, I have not found it to be all that useful for cancer.
I've not seen any studies, baby, I haven't looked lately for cancer. I found it to be extremely helpful
for autoimmune patients, because it could help. So, with an autoimmune condition, you want to
call me a immune response. So, immune regulation is helpful. So, uh, LDN stimulates, what's called
T-reg production. So, T-regs are a type of T cell subset called T-regulator cells that can help
call the immune response in somebody who has a hyperimmune reaction with an autoimmune disease.
Now, there are some people who say that it can eat a T-regulator. It can help
bring up somebody's immune response if it's super suppressed. So, in that case, I could say that it
would be helpful. So, I would say low dose Nell Trexel will be helpful. If somebody's voice
or chemo, and their white blood cell felt is extremely suppressed, and they're struggling with
immune suppression, it could help bring that up. It's not going to be an immune stimulant
where it's going to, you know, help kill cancer, but it could help bring up a suppressed immune response.
So, in that case, I would say it's worth a try. But really, there's not a whole lot of side effects
from taking it. So, I don't think there's anything wrong with giving it a try. They're sure.
Do you think pancreatic enzymes are good to cycle on and off with our supplementation? I used to take
once, six years ago, and was wondering if I should go back on one for any virus tissue.
So, pancreatic enzymes are one of the things that, so it depends on how you're using the pancreatic
enzymes. If you're using the pancreatic enzymes to help with digestion, or you're using
high dose pancreatic enzymes on an empty stomach to help kill cancer by helping break down the
waist layer around the cancer, it's totally different uses there. So, if a person, let's say,
doesn't have active cancer, and they're in remission, and they're doing really well, could they stop
taking high dose pancreatic enzymes for the purpose of cancer, eating and cancer, sell that? I'd say,
yes, you totally say to stop it. If you're taking pancreatic enzymes for the help of digestion,
that is one of the supplements that I would say you shouldn't pulse. You should stay on all of this,
because we always need help with digestion. Because gut issues can be the original source of so many
disorders, because even though you're eating all organic and you're trying to stay so close to a
perfect diet, there's no such thing as a perfect diet in our environment. And you're exposed to
glyphosate, which is an antibiotic that damages your gut epithelial cells on a daily basis,
even if you're eating all organic. And you're exposed to chemicals that are breathing it. And you're
exposed to things that damage your gut and put stress on your pancreas and cause decrease
pancreatic function and decrease pancreatic enzyme production. So helping digest your food is
something you always want to try to stay on top. But if your cancer is in a relative state of
remission and you're doing really well, shouldn't you go back on pancreatic enzymes once in a while?
There's something wrong with pulsing them at that point. So if you're doing a high dose,
let's say you're taking 5, 10, 15, 20, you're the morning, it was same in the evening, 30 to 60 minutes
away from food, you cannot hurt yourself with pancreatic enzymes. So enzymes are building blocks
of everything in your body. So I would say you're fine in doing that, probably be advisable to do that.
Three other questions. In your store, you have a few different kinds, any recommendations.
So again, are you talking about using it for digestion? Or are you talking about using high dose
for cancer? So if you're talking about using them, high dose for cancer and pulsing them,
there's the ones that Dr. Gonzales used are the allergy research pancreatic pork enzymes.
Are those the best ones? No. But some people will be stuck and be faithful to what Dr. Gonzales
taught and understand Dr. Gonzales used those because that's what Dr. Kelly will and Kelly could get
at the time. But Dr. William Kelly, who really put pancreatic enzyme therapy on the map,
who he got it, that information from Dr. Bard. Dr. Bard was well dead with Lord Dr. Kelly
felt that information and he helped cure his old cancer, liver cancer with high dose pancreatic
enzymes. The only ones that were on the market at the time were those pancreatic pork enzymes.
So he used them and she actually had allergy research make them for him for years to use on
patients and it was quite successful. They're great enzymes. They're great. The negative is,
is you have to take a lot of them to get the same dosage as you can get in some of the other ones.
So Dr. William Kelly and Dr. Gonzales, which was he was Dr. William Kelly's protege,
was using upwards 75 to 100 of those in the morning. I have to stomach and 75 to 100
in the evening. I have to stomach. It's a lot of pills to swallow. So the bottles come in a bottle
of 720 cancers. I don't think they're the best ones to use now. I think the best ones that we have are
either the digestimes plus from U.S. enzymes. Then you can take far less of them. Or the
pancreatic ultra 10x ultra from professional formulas. Those are the two best ones we have right now.
And you can take far less. So if you want to take 10 in the morning and 10 at night and do that for
you know, a month and then go off of it for three months and do that again for a month and go
off with the three months. We're doing it for a week and off and for a couple of something like that.
I'll see that that way. That would be the way to go. Digestimes plus from U.S. enzymes. I hate their
name because they have another one digestimes. The labels look very similar and the colors look
very similar. Very bad marketing. Digestimes plus from U.S. enzymes. Or from professional formulas
that they created 10x ultra 10x ultra from professional formulas. My carbohydrate convince me that the L
salameras will eat cancer when he used it. He got a hole in his face. I'm getting a hole in my breast
and I think it has been eating tissue not the tumor. So I'm stopping it. Someone on the internet
said he worked at the CIA and they know that it will cure cancer but are suppressing the information.
He suggested one a day. He must have tested for night a day. Okay, so I tested that it came up one
a day at that time. Well, again, that is a probiotic that is an organism that can help
and it's Laura. Will it eat cancer? I don't know. I don't know. Is that true that somebody on the
internet said that? I don't know. Tell me that somebody else said that but is that actually true
and is the CIA suppressing this information? I don't know what the CIA would have to do with
cancer suppression. FDA certainly would suppress different things because they are getting paid by
the pharmaceutical industries. And if the pharmaceutical industry can't make money out of something,
well, the FDA is going to hold on. It's aggressive because they're just basically another
of those pharmaceutical complex. So is there truth in that? I don't know. Maybe
is that causing a hole in your breasts? I don't know. I don't know. You're taking it forally.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. That's interesting. I'm going to do a little research on that now.
Take into that. That's from sparkly my curiosity. If I find more information on talk about next week,
I'll be on post it on it. Okay, last call for questions. All right, thanks everybody.
God bless everybody. No, I'll be praying for all of you and we'll see you next week.